le monde avait changé la société
britannique tout entière avait changé
vous savez vous êtes mariée avec un
esprit rebelle essayer de dompter ces
personnes là ne sert à rien votre
caractère impulsif devrait déjà
appartenir au passé
la monarchie est trop fragile vous me
l'avez très souvent répété un seul
scandale de plus une humiliation
nationale de plus et tout sera terminé
je sais enfin qui je suis une femme qui
correspond à notre temps libre de vivre
libre d'aimer et de voler de ses propres
ailes qui a causé plus de dommages à la
monarchie des mois avec moi
l'obstination ou alors vous avec votre
inhumanité la grande bretagne a changé
radicalement pourtant la monarchie
poursuit fait petit rituel d'avant
guerre comme si rien de ces débris
qu'est-ce que vous massy theurillat
changeait tout
[Musique]
ne rien faire est souvent la meilleure
chose à faire
l'histoire n'a pas été écrite par ceux
qui n'ont rien fait
je crois que le peuple a le droit de
connaître les gens qui les dirigent
particulièrement ceux qu'on ne peut pas
renverser avec des élections libres et
justes
pas
[Musique]
je suis un joueur respecté par ces
individus savez vous qu actuellement mon
rang est inférieur à celui de mon fils
ya huit ans
[Musique]
elle ne me laisse absolument aucune
possibilité de vous pardonner
la question et e
[Musique]
comment pouvez-vous vous parvenez vous
même
toi
[Musique]